buried under the desert near Waxahachie
Texas is a 14 mile scar on the sole of
American physics the Large Hadron
Collider that runs under Switzerland and
France has been getting a lot of good
press lately they've been smashing
particles together at greater speeds and
energies and has ever been done before
they lead the world in particle physics
and they discovered the Higgs boson or
god particle one of the greatest
discoveries in modern science but there
was another Collider sitting abandoned
in the Texas desert is the remnants of
the superconducting supercollider it
would have been three times as large and
three times as powerful as LHC today it
sits abandoned in the dusty Texas desert
and locals call it the desert drop it
was going to be 51 miles in
circumference
currently the LHC is 17 miles and is
able to smash particles together at
around 13 or 14 tera electron volts that
holds the world record this thing was
gonna smash them together at 40 tera
electron volt or three times the energy
in the u.s. had the jump on this it was
first imagined in the early 1980s and
construction began in 1991 perhaps
once-in-a-lifetime something will happen
that changes the course of history
forever with exotic names like Higgs
bosons squarks and slept on I am
speaking of course about the
superconducting supercollider but two
years later Congress decided that they
could only fund one fancy science
project at a time there was one that was
a little bit sexier than a big tunnel in
the ground the International Space
Station but it wasn't just about the
budget it was also about power
Democratic Senator Jim Slattery made it
his pet project to deep fund the super
collider him and his allies in Congress
called it luxury science funding was
totally pulled the entire project
collapsed they had already invested two
billion dollars dug 14 miles of tunnels
and 2,000 scientists had staked their
future on the
today the tunnels have been flooded with
water to help preserve them the desert
Tron has seen better days the discovery
of the Higgs boson is one of the
greatest scientific achievements of our
modern age and it could have happened in
Texas and it might have happened 10
years earlier and with the ability to
smash particles together at three times
the energy level of LHC who knows what
else we could have found in the words of
a physicist who worked on the project
had to help dismantle it and wrote its
eulogy we gathered all the nation's
elite to help and build mankind's
greatest feat so come we did pursuing
the dream to build a machine that
collides proton beams its pork-barrel
useless garbage they cried off with its
head the house puffed in pride little
was ventured and little was gained
except filling the nation's physicists
with anger and pain subscribe here and
watch more videos here bong star rider
this one is for you